what's going on citizens of the reject Nation we
are about to do a first time watch of Batman under
the Red Hood now even though I'm very familiar
with under the Red Hood I read those Comics well
over a decade ago and I have somehow never seen
this incredibly rated movie Greg thought it'd be
fun to pair me up with John today because as
far as I know you know the character but not
like his machinations he haven't read the comics
you haven't seen the movie and I have a red hood
yes because this is your marketing this is this
is a branding situation yeah exactly no I know
the basics of the character pop culture osmosis
so we're both about to watch it for the first
time so please do leave a like leave a comment
let us know what you thought of this video and
as always if you want to do a full length sync
up with your own copy watch long head over to
the real rejects patreon page where we've got a
one-to-one setup join us for the whole Adventure
the whole journey now before going into this
I did want to mention the channel geek that is
g-i-q-u-e I've got an exclusive video over there
actually two and so does Greg now what geek does
is these incredible one minute character videos
everything from the pop culture impact to their
origin stories you can really get a lot of data
from this site all at once and it's got content
from a wide variety of creators and that's why
we really wanted to shine a spotlight in them
today so not only is it a great place to get
extra geeky content but if you're a content
creator yourself and you're trying to get some
more exposure you can also potentially get paid
to produce these one minute shorts I've got
a couple of videos over there I dive into the
Red Hood himself because I love this character
but also wanted to give some love to one of my
favorite characters of all time Miguel O'Hara
Spider-Man 2099 and Greg's got some mysterious
video over there that he won't tell me what it is
but I'm gonna look at geeked and I'm gonna find
out so it'd be great if you guys could check
out geek we really want to shine a spotlight
in them I love what they're doing now not only
for the geek Community but also for creators it
is a great communal experience over there sharing
knowledge and exposure for creators and geek them
alike so we are thrilled to be partnering with
them as we dive into Batman under the Red Hood
[Music]
I like these Vibes starting well I'm very excited
yeah this I've heard is one of the best DC
animated films and DC is usually that's their jam
I should never have Allied myself with a Madman
he has the boy oh oh no Robin
that looked like it really hurt
Thriller I mean obviously obviously the
Riddler you can start this thing with
a crowbar clay face all right what
hurts more a okay or B forehand ah
this is pretty intense a little
laugh I think you may have a collapsed
lung that always impedes the oratory
[Laughter]
oh man he won't make it there in time
nah Batman's always on time like a wizard
please tell the big man I said hello
[Laughter] whose voice yeah it's
a different joke in the dark
use those acrobatic skills
there's those contortions
dude the bike looks rad
oh
you knew it knew this was coming Pete and
in the comics this was all by a fan vote
Jim Starlin gave fans the option to call a
number to vote with a robin lived or died
and fans voted to kill Robin and it was
a tight vote it was like down to 56 or
something insane but but they killed Robin
via 1-900 number you are monsters you Jesus
Jason rip Jason Todd anti-opened the Red
Hood movie yeah that was pretty chilling
that was very cool I'm guessing
Bruce Greenwoods are Bruce
Jensen Ackles yeah I imagine he's a red
hooded so excited John DiMaggio is he
our Joker I could hear that I can't hear his
voice Timbre in there and NPH who's he gonna be
oh look at that too that's gorgeous
Gotham City city is a sewer that needs its cover
replaced it's very shiny but you know off kilton
like Gotham it's what underneath that defines
you God I love this you should make a list video
of the best Batman stories that don't start
with the words Gotham City that's a top one
I like the blend of CGI and hand-drawn
animation so far yeah it's well chosen
gorgeous a nice blend of the classic
animated series some comic input this
is a beautiful Gotham there's nothing
like an animated movie Gotham yeah truly
wasn't my meat how the hell with this I'm going
your brain donors want to hang around sit down
brain donors movie reference
yeah who the hell are you smoking
not Batman I'm offering you morons a deal you go
about your business as usual but kick up 40 to me
in return you will have total protection
from both black mask and Batman but you
stay away from kids in school yards but
why the hell should we listen to you
that's my workout bag gains black mask
those are the heads of all your lieutenants
you want to see what I can
get done in a whole evening
I'm not asking you to kick in with me
I'm telling you oh that's a triple tap
to eat 40 works for me good intro for the
Red Hood that's great just an Ackles sounds
younger which would make sense but still
it's taking me back you asked me what 12
13 years ago yeah just grab them up
screw it just go get us out of here
I think I lost him you think
I lost them I think he lost
I think you lost him no you're anything but good
oh mother right
who are you working for nobody lie to me again and
crashing into a wall head-on will be the
least painful activity of your evening oh
oh what is that your cargo
but you weren't doing nothing it's called
Amazo a highly Advanced cybernetic Android
equipped with the ability to absorb the power of
superhumans what kind of superhumans all for one
Pack's quite the punch for a toaster
on steroids huh hey Nightwing yeah
oh nice
foreign
yeah buddy get the higher ground
no he could fly oh
I wouldn't be offended by a
few suggestions he has the
same weak points as a human being got
it kick him in the nuts eyes got tears
man we didn't Nightwing in a movie so
bad Nightwing's awesome it's one of
the few like remaining characters
we really haven't seen you yeah
yeah nice I don't think eyes it's gonna hurt
him oh that's C4 come on Nightwing oh yeah
it was smart to use Amazo like I I like the blend
of different villains because like I don't think
of a meso as a Red Hood story but now we
have them together oh cool Let It Go Right
for the Red Hood we don't have any choice
wow the shots came from the
rooftop a sniper a good one yeah
excellent deduction Robin see him nightmare
yeah oh look at this one building and find him
hey wait Batman's sort of a dick
oh that like heat Ripple yeah the really
really smart use of foreground
background with the animation
see he doesn't use guns he uses things and I was
about to say if you like if he if he just shoots
the car he's gonna like Massacre this tunnel in
the process yeah the smart [Applause] [Music]
it's all part of the Hood's plan though
I got you right where he wants yeah
at a chili Factory delicious
it's gonna be ace chemicals
because that's what I assume they'd tie in wait
I'm not a truck I swear oh no
The Riddler his origin story
Edward Enigma favorite character
in a way Batman this was the sight of your
first great failure maybe your greatest
but certainly not your last right ah memories oh
spicy boots dang almost became the Batman who
laughs just then how many times the ace chemical
plant is to float up the ace chemical plant must
be impossible to ensure that's my next list how
many best Ace chemical explosion and that's
why there are no competitors in town it's not
worth it it's the only chemical place yeah several
criminals have utilized this Persona one criminal
of particular interest though huh but he's locked
up it's a fun way to tell a lot of story in a
couple seconds that's right man yeah exposition
maybe we should go for a visit could you just once
[Music] I feel like that was an mph ad-lib
I wonder like how much they let him just
play yeah it's like I'm just sticking in a wide
shot you know what do you know about it that he
has horrible taste when I wore that number it was
classy more flashy Mater D than motorcycle fetish
better off than his replacement right even
tougher making with the yucks when your worm food
good clue you really think I would stir up so
much trouble and not make sure you knew it was
me that is a solid Point I've always left the
Joker in so many ways is smarter than Batman
you idiots know how many bitters I had
on a meso a list of puppet dictators and
psychos as long as my arm Millions
shot right to hell and whose money
money your money my money oh yeah who blows the
damn robot's head off I could have at least sold
it for scrap Batman kept it yes Batman
likes to keep things glass man collects
penny a dinosaurs okay really it's all bought
and paid for so this is strictly a delivery not
a buy but in view of recent events I've taken
the liberty of doubling the security detail
and switching the drop spot that sounds like a
plan I like how the audio engineer like mixed
those like that one line and three different
audio Styles so it gave it more like depth
[Music]
okay I won't be staying that long
you know what I missed most about running with you
the toys not done you want to dance let's dance
[Music] okay I'll just take care of this I like
the slight Odd Couple humor between the Nightwing
oh no oh
cool awesome
oh my God
Red Hood plays video games
that's how to use props well
I love how many low-flying blimps
Gotham has too way more than all
the United States the blimp ratio much higher
[Music] nah don't don't discount yourself
I love how many explosions he is throwing at him
yes like the ultimate clue hidden in plain sight
he's been trained and trained well like right
there that he sliced that cable off his ankle
before it went taut you don't just do that oh wait
ow Alfred take him home Bruce I can still help
you already have thank you [Laughter]
this is like me and Greg in the office thank you
thank you okay hobbles out makes some thumbnails
oh here we go [Music] you haven't
lost your touch bro [Laughter]
it's funny I probably maybe have questioned
that before but now I know that software exists
yeah we live in a scary time yeah I've
used that software [Music] oh the memory
foreign
like the the way the the revealing stuff
hey it's a joke hey it's the curve
finally Nemesis it's over Riddler
[Music]
nice what's green and purple
but covered in red and yellow
ouch when I land on your sorry butt don't move
we're up you're white shoot me oh nice nice
Robin I didn't think I had to prop up some pillows
before I took him out he would have talked but you
put him into shock that was dumb but he deserved
it I like how quickly they were able to summarize
like even just the shock like the the ability
of to get what they needed out of them and like
why aggressive Vengeance doesn't work because that
even like all the people that think Batman should
use guns like there's all this summarizes all
the reasons you have to have a skill [Applause]
foreign
hood is that right
The Rusty Nail you're a club owner and some big
damn drug dealer in the East quarter right you
stupid bags of manners fatty I don't care who
takes care of you you watch your mouth you don't
gotta body shame the guy it's the real villainy
but on top of all the things you're doing to them
was sending your boss a message
oh [Music]
what's the message
a simple one actually
want to guess what it might be
they looked bulletproof yeah
[Music]
even know who I am
oh
no you four of all this power and
all you do is it is kill for money
from what I hear we've got that
in common you heard wrong oh yeah
oh the fight hasn't started yet I'm just stalling
oh
what the hell took you so long shut up and fight
shut up and be my sidekick
because I know who you are now
nice
[Music]
he got Boba fetted right into the sarlacc pit
[Laughter]
oof yes
I think Jensen Ackles one of the only voice actors
that could also play the character in real life
like of cast like I could see him oh sure you know
what I mean I would be so psyched I mean we got
soldier boy but we're at the same time to see him
in a right in a non-satirical universe let him go
step away taser Naomi and you'll electrocute
both of us has in mind oh nice ouch oh
that's a supernatural blood splatter tell me what
happened to you let me help you had your chance
it's not too late it's never too late
people gotta know by now he's got
that mask but he used his own ninja
smoke bomb against him as he usually uses that
defensively he was like Bob offensive [Music]
the red blade test that blood make sure it's
who thinks it is now it's a very convoluted
way in the comic books so I'm very curious
what the movie does to make this linear
oh Alfred you want to tell me why this
guy ain't dead we're trying we sent the
Fearsome hand of four that rolls off the tongue
guess they're gonna need a new name why hasn't
Batman wiped this little smear off the face
of the planet perhaps he's letting you in the
he could be waiting to take on the
winner these guys is waiting around
just lining them up can't you feel it
oh
hahaha
blow it up anyway
who knows he's leaving it's
gonna be a sleepover right
I'll pack my toothbrush and my yellow
toothpaste got a brand to uphold
you need more lights huh don't open
it with a crowbar Bruce have some tact
it's opening with my bird I mean don't use the
weapon that killed him I'm just saying Bruce
loves a little Irish he's just sub it come on
it's gonna bring you right back out of the ground
is still at rest no he isn't that's not flesh
oh my it's a real doll where are
you going to talk to the man who did
that get the bodies are preserved but it
would not look like just a kid I'm just
saying Batman you look better than the day
you died a lot of money a lot of dead meat
[Laughter]
Funyuns I need you to murder the Red Hood
may I have some water
oh yeah wowie I'll need some guys not
these guys because well they're kind
of dead black mask is having the
worst day just having a tough go
of being a crime lord it's not
easy I almost feel bad for you
race finds I am curious what they meant when
they spelled it our Apostrophe a s oh yeah
what did you do to Jason you remember when
we last became embattled you were planning
to blow up Banks accurative but you were on to
me I sought a distraction so I hired the Joker
it was to appear that you had stumbled upon him
oh yeah he was paid extremely well what
was intended to be a wild goose chase
he murdered the boy I had hoped
to return to you what you had lost
whoa I achieved this by bathing in the
rejuvenating Waters of the Lazarus Pier
it has long been rumored that it is capable
of an even greater feat to raise the Dead
what makes sense with the way it is named and
all it took was a few payoffs to replace his body
it had unfortunate results
oh cool just dropping a
dead kid in the Lazarus Pit
[Music]
he returned move but returned damaged wow
great not great Bob shall I alert the guards
to pursue him don't be foolish they would never
catch him besides I have done enough yeah you
keep messing up that Rush I do love that aspect
he's like I've made enough trouble here I
might be over here sorry man ah we lost him
your fault what's a bad miracle nope he's taken
everything I've ever taught him and turned it on
me it's a hell of my own making Alfred so this
is not your doing you loved him he knows that
it should be enough not Gonna Make Room for love
in that utility belt no pouch for it that is here
this wasn't part of the damn deal you freak I
thought you'd enjoy you think I care if that
scum dies don't know I just wanted your
attention you've always had my attention
but what I really wanted was an audience with you
now you have my curiosity sure I had lots
of plans but the end game was getting better
it took a lot of work to bring about
our reunion reunion have we met before
yes we have that's what I was hinting at reunion
[Music]
whoa he really was cool with it
oh sweet shot
I've got him you want him meet
me at Crime Alley ooh his origin
versus your origin we're going all the big spots
what's the plan slumber party charades a
little Truth or Dare yes I'll start with dare
well maybe I'll just go [Music]
oh boy oh
I gotta know who are you you said we knew
one another and you do seem really familiar
we double at the prom no I'm just something
you helped make pretty critic [Music]
ghost of Batman past unreal Joker got away
this Ends Tonight all of it
nobody knows that better than me
cool weaponized dumpster
that's my favorite [Laughter]
oh that's smart
oh
damn
using the cape against him never have a cape
ow oh that's a cool detail yeah the
Kevlar underneath yeah underneath
oh
yes look at you
Jason
I know what happened oh you got to talking
with race huh or is this just the real me
damn
oh
what bothers you more at your greatest failure has
returned from the grave or that I've
become a better Batman than you hey
enough it's over oh [Music]
I know I failed you but I tried to
save you Jason Bruce I forgive you
for not saving me why on
God's Earth is he still alive
hahaha
Gotta Give the boy points get all
the way back from the dead to me
I thought I'd be the last person you'd ever let
him hurt a day doesn't go by when I don't think
about subjecting him to every horrendous
torture he's dealt out to others and then
end him oh so you do think about me
I'm doing it because he took me away from
you I can't well you won't have a choice
huh if you want to stop me you're gonna have
to kill me you know I won't I'm gonna blow this
derang's brains out and if you want to stop it
you're gonna have to shoot me right in my face
this is turning out even better than this
side now do it ham or me decide
oh foreign
[Laughter]
that's the ultimate joke oh
oh goody no don't spoil it
I'm the only one who's gonna get
what he wants tonight yes bang
bang boom we all go out together
don't you just love a happy ending
Gotham is a rough place to live yeah people just
used to explosions constantly does your home have
decimation insurance meanwhile The Joker has
been returned to Arkham Asylum officials there
claim that extra measures have been taken to
ensure that another Escape would be impossible
oh good till next time [Music] Jason get on
out here or I'm going on Patrol without you
come on Old Man we've got bad guys who need
chasing this is the best day of my life huh
oh buddy damn what a note to end
on yeah you're right okay Bruce
Greenwood oh Jason Isaacs was Ross struggle
got it and John DiMaggio was the Joker cool
I don't remember Bobo but Gary Cole was Bobo hey
Bobo is my it's Bobo's my favorite
character I mean who doesn't love
so many fun comic collecting memories of Bobo
so many Bobo graphic novels just really trade
paperbacks that's my next list best Bobo up
here that's the compendium of all the books
it's a coffee table it's the size of my coffee
tables I've got you know first edition Prince
of Bobo that's right that collect uh fine Bobo
memorabilia just got back from Bobo Khan myself
this weekend oh dude I love bobobelia you know
it's an international market but Bobo uh resale
value is is off the charts yeah that's right
man that was great that was really good yeah
yeah like I was again I felt did this come out
in the theater like this felt like a theatrical
caliber I think the run time would prohibit that
I guess so uh anything more than like one of those
like oh you know for one weekend or something yeah
Special engagement Dragon Ball Z I know has like
those one weekend releases or whatever and like my
hero Academia but I don't know if DC has because
it's a lot of like legalese and stuff but I think
run time's an issue um they should they could cram
this in like a hundred times yeah I mean they
should these are well worth it yeah absolutely
they definitely like there's a market for it too
I know so many people that swear by these movies
uh and a lot of people I think you know get access
to these stories through the the DC animated films
like I I don't I know these do better than the
comics as far as getting awareness for stories
like this really well yeah cause like you knew the
Red Hood um you know before this but I feel like
a lot of people wouldn't have until the movie
because a lot of people don't read the books
so like this would be an access point and then
they might go back and read the comics that's
why I always think like these are always great
to exist I'm happy that they make them because
yeah it does seem like again they seem to have
a really good grip on them and there's so much
you know I think beloved history especially
with DC when it comes to animated you know
yeah moving animation well I think they've earned
a certain amount of like Goodwill where it's like
oh any story they make is gonna like this is the
leveling up like now people will go read the comic
because it got animated because of the Goodwill
of the animation Universe yeah and it's like I
appreciate that even if it's not the purest form
even if it is not the comic book it is you know
very much I mean not to slight live-action movies
and stuff sure but yeah it's like the the halfway
point it's the moving animation it's it's you
know they can take Liberties but also you know
I'm sure it's clearly inspired by you know iconic
cells well and I and I don't remember uh like I
said I've read the comics since wow uh I think
probably the year it came out like I think I
read it as it was being released so it's been you
know 20 oh God you know over more than 15 years
um but like I don't remember a meso being in it
and I thought that was a really clever you know
to bring in a character that might not normally
get a a release you know uh now people know
that character and what a great way to to bring
Nightwing in and like to do all those things so it
was really smart like using continuity and playing
around with mythology and like incorporating those
things oh yeah one I mean Amazo this would be
the first time I am like knowingly seeing that
character so for me that's yeah that's a bit
of an introduction and uh and two like I really
appreciate the way that yeah you get Nightwing
in here to show to literally you know embody the
alternate outcome to all of this well and you in
this one movie this is an hour and 15 minutes and
they were able to do a decent job with black mask
Joker Riddler Amazo Red Hood like the the power of
the animation stuff is if you use these archetypal
characters and and characters you know like we
didn't see anything with Riddler really but what
a great little like side mission and like Raj al
Ghul like we we know who he is so it works for
the storyline I don't remember which continuity
ended up being the one they landed on for Red Hood
but for some reason I'm remembering Red Hood as
a character that got brought back through like
uh um like an Earth 2 thing like there was some
cataclysmic event that shifted that caused him
to be able to come back from the dead but like
this was literally 20 years ago when I read it
so I I don't remember like I might be mixing up
hush in Red Hood but like I'm trying to remember
it wasn't the Lazarus Pit I don't remember rosh
being involved okay but I could be wrong like I
said it's been it's been long enough that like I
could you know a drinking age has occurred like I
think it's been about 20 years because I was gonna
ask then you know like how does this stack up to
the comic book story and does the comic book story
as you recall it you know I mean maybe not having
racial ghoul but did it have as many I feel like
any Batman ark or story is going to have multiple
villains showing up and multiple characters you
know of importance aside from the main focus
and the main person being pursued or whatever
um but this this felt like really well populated
in a way that I don't know like made me think of
the the couple other of the animated movies I've
seen in the animated show and that you feel like
you have just this this community of Rogues and
characters who are all kind of just around the
corner or in Arkham Asylum doing their thing yeah
and so at least here I'm I would be curious to
know yeah like who got added in or who was already
there in the source material to begin with because
I I liked the array of characters they used
and like you said in movies like these are fun
and fascinating to me because it is a short run
time and yet it doesn't feel rushed and all the
characters who show up feel like they got their
you know they they were honored in the time that
they were there on screen like you said even the
Riddler who's only in one little side sequence
and you know still feels like that presence you
know was punctuated and I do feel I just looked
up it was 2005. so it's been 18 years yeah uh
which is insane but uh adult that's adult child
someone born the year this came out can vote yeah
don't love that um but uh to me they Incorporated
those villains really well in the comic storyline
I don't remember it as clearly I do remember there
being like a greatest hits of villains um I always
thought of Red Hood and hush as very similar kind
of story lines and I think there's a reason they
stand out like hush to me is kind of like a Now
That's What I Call Batman Rogues because he's like
trying to solve all the villains to get to the
thing and then this is the other direction this
is kind of the inverse where it's other villains
need to be used to build up Red Hood yeah so in in
hush he's kind of like chipping away and like and
like uh removing variables whereas Red Hood it's
kind of like showing building up it's showing the
strength of the Red Hood by him being able to
take them out yeah so what I remember the Red
Hood was like he's so powerful that he's able to
squash blankety blankety blankety blank and that
shows the power of red hood so while I don't
remember the individual villains I do remember
there being like this guy's awesome because he's
taking everybody out you know what I mean and
he's clearly demonstrating that he knows through
and through the the you know things that Batman
would have imparted on him over all those years
we're actually working together so yeah you get
this badass who has that one step ahead kind of
uh you know intellect and special set of skills
yeah and who can also then give Batman a good run
for his money as well you know and this proceeds
Winter Soldier like I I also like that this is
you know a character that is kind of the the
you know Bucky to the Steve Rogers like this is
the character that comes back from the dead that
is wronged that shows the weakness in all of his
thoughts and abilities and kind of shows the the
Folly in his heroic Duty yeah oh man you owe a lot
to like winter soldier owes a lot to Red Hood uh
because even like in this this came out in 2010
uh I think that Winter Soldier was what 2015.
that knife fight in this they were taking notes
look there was literally a memory stab stab drop
grab might have seen that in a certain live-action
movie starring a character that's very similar and
I don't know why you're talking I hadn't seen
this until today so I was watching this like 20
like the choreography at moments and I've always
thought of red hood as uh kind of the the sins of
the father to the character uh like there's this
really beautiful relationship between Batman and
his Robins as like Batman lost his family so he
builds the bat family like Batman lost everything
that was family to him except Alfred so he and
Alfred build out this family and who he couldn't
save was the character that I think is most like
him because if you look at Batman Origin stories
like the year one stuff is always Batman trying
to squash that Vengeance he's he is the Vengeance
he's the Knight but he doesn't want to kill Jason
Todd even says like would have gone on to do wrong
you know like he's the guy that would have been
if if Batman didn't solve his Vengeance to a level
where he can control himself that's Jason Todd so
I always thought it was interesting they killed
Jason's Todd so he didn't get to become the evil
Batman so bringing him back it's it's even more so
like I I love the Batman Joker parallel because
it's your one rule I have no rules Jason Todd
is literally if Batman didn't have the moral
code to develop the one rule it becomes blank
so he doesn't yeah he doesn't just become the
Joker or something right yeah he's his own thing
and that's why I think Batman is one of the best
characters in the history of fiction is he is so
multifaceted he has more than one opposite yeah
totally two faces is opposite Jokers is opposite
red hood is his opposite like he's so archetypal
he's so full of integrity and Pathos and in like
I think and I love you know Spider-Man Deadpool
and all those characters I think the only truly
Shakespearean fiction character in comicton
is is Batman because he's able to have so
much tragedy and and Shakespeare's so tragic
uh and I'm not saying that Spider-Man's not
tragic like please don't don't take that for a a
lessening but when you look at Shakespeare it's
a tragic figure and I think the reason Batman
registered with so many people is that he is
so much Shakespearean that you can re-translate
him in so many different ways like these great
you know powerful sonnets and plays yeah and that
includes his villains for sure and I mean I really
enjoyed the way this this made me think of two
things one this made me think of I was watching a
a video essay recently up on the importance of
Robin and and kind of asking why especially the
live-action movies seem very averse to Robin and
and it brought up that idea that you're talking
about whereas you know like Bruce Wayne learns
to you know cure an aspect of himself that would
lead him down this very dark and toxic and and
you know violent Road and then is able to yeah
pass that on and create some sort of hole in
bringing on you know a ward whom he sees you
know that potential for both you know his type of
heroics but also for that you know tragic turn and
I love the way that they Incorporated all that
here but also the way that yeah like you have
this great like I love love love that came down
to this showdown between Red Hood and Joker and
Batman and this whole thing about like he you were
watching him you know Traverse and climb the the
web and pyramid of Gotham's crime yeah but then
it all comes down to this really personal thing
and it all comes down to this overlapping set of
plans and you know you've got like you know the
more uh uh you know you've got the people on the
back foot of that like uh Black Mask who who think
they're in control and really aren't in control
but then you've got characters like Batman and
the Joker and red hood who are all kind of Chess
piecing around and who are all very smart and I
like the way that the writing brought both the
physical you know planning to the Forefront of
how brilliant you know these machinations are
but also examined a fair amount of the themes
about you know killing and why Batman shoes is
the kind of morality he does and I like that
they allow even though you know that they're not
going to agree like Jason uh um Jason Todd makes
good points about how ruling through fear or you
know can be problematic and you know even though
you know his approach isn't right in trying to
take and control all the crime you're like well
I get this approach though and especially given
the experiences you've had and the loss that you
experienced I get why you would turn out this way
and so it's like you have this thing that feels
very fitting of you know a story about this master
detective and you know the people surrounding him
but you also have yeah something that's uh I
don't know it felt very smart and clever to a
degree that is you know that you want I feel like
anytime you're watching superheroes and villains
you want to feel like there is some kind of master
plan that does take a little bit of detecting that
that does involve you know intellect and that
you want to feel you know a little bit smart for
keeping up yeah you want to feel clever yeah and
I feel like they did that really well with all the
characters here and then also took it that extra
mile with being you know pretty emotional and you
know paying off the Resonance of the relationships
and also through the voice acting like I loved
I mean you know I I feel like obviously Kevin
Conroy is like the gold standard may he rest in
peace but I like Bruce uh I liked uh being under
the green wood with uh Bruce Greenwood as Batman
and I thought uh uh uh Jensen Ackles was terrific
I kept picturing Jensen ankles which is fun like I
I like halfway through and I was like he's one of
the only voice actors that could also be Jason's
Todd Red Hood like a lot of I can't picture
Bruce Greenwood as Bruce Wayne no disrespect
Bruce I don't see that whereas Jensen Ackles I'm
like man if they did a live action Red Hood like
love to see him get to play and his voice is like
so dominant and interesting and I I definitely
think the The Duality between even like Nightwing
and Jason Todd is a fun thing you could play with
and I'd love to see uh them get into the movies
but and this is going to be people are gonna be
mad at me for saying this I'm not gonna say it
anyway uh I you brought up a few minutes ago them
wanting Robins in the movies I think the reason
we haven't gotten to have a robin in the last 10
years of movies is because they've made in except
for Pattinson but that's because he's a year one
Batman you're two technically but he's an early
Batman I think Ben Affleck's Batman was too close
to Red Hood okay so if you've got a character
that is already willing to use guns if you've
got a character that's already willing to kill
if you've got then what's your separation between
your failure as a parent sure like how do you
separate like you need a paternal Batman in order
to make a ward feel like he's being protected by
Family yeah we didn't develop the Batman in the
Batman vs Superman Universe enough to make him
paternal enough to make him we had the the prick
from fashionable mail from Mallrats as Batman and
he walked around with that you know arrogance and
I love you guys I'm on record for saying how great
Ben Affleck is is Batman but the portrayal choice
of making him I'm doing this thing arrogantly is
Bruce Wayne the real Bruce Wayne is very uh broken
um uh he's got a he's a shell of a man that lashes
is out he he doesn't want this alien to uh take
everything that he's believed in he doesn't want
to he's so protective but it's in a way that he's
uh he's he's a corned animal like I see Ben
Affleck's Bruce Wayne as like someone who's
lost so much he's cornered that's not someone
who could raise a child that's not someone who
could rear a robin so therefore when Nightwing
is killed or when that Robin's killed and you
see that whole thing I can't picture a storyline
where Ben Affleck could raise that Robin in a way
that he wouldn't just become red red hood yeah and
then it would be more toxic and uncomfortable to
watch right so like when Batman's like you know
driving his Batmobile and shooting people you'd
like that guy can't then raise someone like the
lessons taught in this animated movie couldn't
be taught with that interpretation of Batman I'm
not saying any Batman's right or wrong but the
ones we've seen lately are either too young or
they have you know some some Vendetta issues a
la redhood sure and I mean there is also the the
thing I think often gets touched upon which is
yet an animated or a comic format it easier
to accept you know like a big grown man and
a kid right running around and I was thinking
that too while I was watching this is you know
I love a live-action superhero movie and I love
watching the game of how do we blend fantasy with
naturalism and reality and how do we make it feel
real but watching something like this is such a
joy because you do have that quintessential Middle
Ground to play with where yeah you have like such
outlandish characters right and a lot of fantasy
uh but at the same time the way the world Works
Blends the two perfectly it's like you still get
the grit and you still get the darker tones and
themes and they don't feel undercut by things
like humor or outlandish looking villains or
you know even again like uh someone like Amazon
who I'm like who is this guy kooky name and yeah
so like I feel like there's a beautiful blend
to be appreciated that you can kind of I'm not
gonna say you could only get an animation but
that is very quintessential to animation and
that is a facet of comics that I kind of miss
and like when I watch Sky High recently not
that this is in any way in that tonal wheel how
house but that movie had a certain element of
color pop and I don't know vibrancy or something
like that there's like a sense of fun that feels
very quintessentially comic book but it feels
like we are much too cool for now yeah and it's
like here like I love to what NPH brought to I
thought he was a really good voice cast choice for
Nightwing but also I really like their humorous
back and forth because then you do feel like yeah
Batman is like the paternal figure but who's also
just really focused a lot of the time he's got the
compassion but a lot of the time he's just very
much about the cases about you know the the matter
at hand and then you've got Dick Grayson over here
who's like you couldn't you know you couldn't help
me out over here come on this is just once
just let's go to the car yeah and it's like
you can have both exist at the same time in this
media and and have it you know feel very vital in
all aspects and I really love that because it's
movies like this or you go back and watch like
mask of the Phantasm and things like that and
you're like these can be so fun and imaginative
but also you know they can move in and touch you
just like a drama you know yeah they can invest
you that way too and it's like an the animation I
love the animated awesome like the density of the
story like I don't think you could make a live
action hour movie that would work do you know
what I mean like all the things you just described
plus the density of it like you know because you
immediately accept black masks look you don't have
to you don't have to write around it you just go
like this is crazy yeah yeah yeah yeah and then it
allows you you know one big moment of Supernatural
here we're gonna do a Lazarus Pit right now you
know we're gonna resurrect somebody you know
um bandaged up like a mummy it's like yeah
suspension of disbelief is within five minutes
and as long as the voice acting is strong enough
you don't feel like it's cheapened like you you're
you're suspension of this belief only works if
everything else is so true and I feel like really
good voice actors have the ability to to bring
you the humanity even without the eyes yeah and
like I I've been on record like I really struggle
with animation but I'm more and more trying to
you know connect and if it's this quality like
I'm fully invested like at no point was I like
distracted like I was fully in for that whole
whole journey because the actors kept me yeah in
there and the animators obviously but I was I was
so invested in these characters no it's everything
because yeah I think it was well written I like
again not having as much of a reference for the
adaptation quality of the writing I thought
it was just well written in proportion because
I've seen a couple of the animated movies and I
remember watching what was it we saw that I think
the killing joke in the theaters and there were
issues I had with like how that was uh you know
handled and proportioned and things like that
but yeah this kind of had the sweet spot for me
where I'm like it was fun it's very imaginative
it's got a lot of Rogues in it but also it has
a lot of the quintessential Batman themes that
are unpacked in a way that feels satisfying and
that feels like you are getting it more than just
ah let's do a fun Batman adventure yeah and then
yeah you have an intriguing villain and also you
know anti-potential anti you know you're sitting
here watching this going is there a chance to
reclaim uh Red Hood it's like yeah you have
so much great animation to sell the punch of
everything and then so much great voice acting
to sell the emotion of everything and uh and yeah
like I said I loved hearing Jensen Ackles and I'm
very curious now to hear him go on to play Batman
because here hearing him much earlier it's like
watching Supernatural you know yeah I've heard
his voice age over the years so this is you know
back you know almost 10 years ago yeah so now
I'm like okay this is definitely younger Jensen
Ackles definitely makes sense for Jace and Todd
and then I know he'll play Bruce Wayne down the
line and I cannot wait uh to hear that but even uh
you know John DiMaggio I thought was a good Joker
yeah and that's hard to you know have an animated
Batman yeah exactly like I wasn't listening for
Kevin Conrad Markham that's no easy feat yeah
totally and uh and yeah you know I didn't catch
who played Alfred but Alfred was in the movie
solid enjoyed him when he was there good little
moments yeah yeah I had a great time with it yeah
likewise man this was this was a slam dunk for me
I'm glad we're doing more of these because uh
that was that was really fun and I like didn't
know what to expect I just know the bar is high
so whenever people talk about DC animation I'm
like I assume spectacular so like you know it
kept up to a very high bar of entertainment I
very very consciously didn't reread the comic
but now I'm excited too like I'm glad I don't
get to often go this way my brain is usually like
oh reference reference and instead now I'm going
like it's been long enough that I don't remember
it well which is nice so I can watch these movies
like fans and then go and read it after which is
what I think the average person does like I think
the average person gets to see a movie and then go
like oh I wonder what that was like in the comic
so now I'm going to reread it and have a good
time well that's that's an approach I like to
to borrow something I pulled off C Robert Cargill
once on the podcast he was like a lot of people
try to read Source material then go watch the
movie which can create a narrowing experience
whereas he said he prefers watching the thing
and then going back for the source material so
it's a more broadening experience or at least
a more you know uh multi-faceted yeah you're
seeing what the other ideas could be in a way that
engages your imagination rather than just seeing
made some good stuff check out black phone uh
but I I do think uh that's what I'll be doing
for this DC animated is a lot of them are from
comics from the early 2000s mid-2000s uh into
the 2010s but all of that is 15 years old or
more so uh while we do these DC animated live
uh watch-alongs I definitely want to read them
after so don't don't expect to call a comic Corner
approach of minutia breakdown because I wanna I
wanna experience these as you guys do and then
eventually we'll list all the most and then I'll
rank the most accurate after the fact 2024 when
we get through all 87 of these just yell at Greg
so he keeps wanting to make them well guys keep a
lookout for that you wanna you wanna you got any
more thoughts before we close out I think that's
it just uh let us know what you thought of this
leave a comment if you like us doing these DC
anime if you want to see us watch more of these
because there's a bunch we haven't seen oh yeah
let us know in the comments which ones uh which
ones your favorite are why you want us to watch
those what you thought of our watch if this one
was uh do you think this is a worthy adaptation
what did you think of Jensen what did you think
of Bruce what did you think of Joe DiMaggio
that's named Joe dimag is that a baseball team
DiMaggio he was a baseball player wasn't he I
believe so yeah it sounds like a baseball player
if comment below let me know if Maggio was a
baseball player like this sounds immediately
right and wrong and uh please do like subscribe
hit that notification Bell and send this to
your friends because this needs to get some
views so we can keep doing them that's how YouTube
works all right you lovelies that is gonna do it
you good citizens of reject Nation we appreciate
you and have a happy holiday we'll see you soon
thank you